e g i f so many things to do here in
town but what if instead you just want
to do something a little more chill like
watching a movie but how do you know if
the movie is worth the watch that is
where our very own jillian lopez comes
in because from now on she'll be giving
you a front row seat to what's new in
theaters jillian thank you mercedes so
yes i am a huge movie and tv buff so i'm
really excited to bring you my reviews
recaps and ratings and i can't think of
a better movie to kick it off with and
one that involves a dog and channing
tatum the movie dog follows the
misadventures of army ranger jackson
briggs played by channing tatum and army
k9 lulu who take a road trip down the
pacific coast in hopes of making it to a
fellow
soldier's funeral on time along the way
they learn what it takes to unleash
inner happiness
we don't do anything else psychotic on
this trip maybe we can have some fun is
that a deal shake
they're both struggling in ways that
maybe they haven't before and the only
difference between them is that one's a
canine one's a human we had retired army
rangers as full-time consultants who
became dear friends and they're all dog
handlers and i'm insanely proud of the
way in which we were able to work with
that community
so good
you are so good
and then to have channing working with
the dogs backplate lulu
that was awesome i mean that's the
foundational
relationship of our movie let's not make
this
all emotional
[Music]
what i loved most about this movie is it
was just mainly channing tatum and lulu
on screen the whole time so you really
got to see their bond develop this was
channing tatum's directorial debut and
he had one rule before taking on this
role but it kind of spoils the ending so
i'm going to save that for another time
this is a movie that will make you smile
and laugh but also pulls on your
heartstrings if you are a dog lover dog
is a must-see and it's out in theaters
now i think we're all dog lovers it's
amazing i think so too